die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und ein
herzliches willkommen norbert lehmann
ist auch dabei für den sparten ein
schwimmender antwort von mir
israel hat gewählt entschieden ist aber
nichts ministerpräsident benjamin
netanjahu und sein herausforderer benny
gantz liegen fast gleichauf wäre das
land künftig regieren wird ist völlig
unklar
mehr als 90 prozent der stimmen sind
ausgezählt netanjahus rechtsgerichteter
likud kommt demnach auf 31 sitze im
parlament
die liste blau-weiß von ex
generalstabschef ganz hat 32 sitze wir
regieren will braucht mindestens 61
sitze eine koalition der beiden würde
die erreichen
aber der steht einiges im weg glück wald
berichtet so sehr man sich auch in die
zahlen vertieft übersichtlicher ist das
politische schachbrett nach der wahl
nicht netanya verfehlte sein ziel
zusammen mit seinen ultrareligiösen
koalitionspartnern eine mehrheit zu
erringen
trotz des bescheidenen abschneidens
seiner likud partei will er aber
regierungschef bleiben wie er das
praktisch erreichen will sagte er heute
nicht
wir werden gemeinsam eine starke
zionistische regierung bilden die gut
für den staat israel ist sein rivale
ganz chef der stärksten fraktion im
neuen parlament plädierte für eine große
koalition mitglied ohne die ultra
religiösen ob netanjahu regierungschef
bleiben kann ließ er offen
wir brauchen jetzt eine regierung der
nationalen einheit die die interessen
der gesamtbevölkerung vertritt eine
meinung die nicht nur von ganz anhängern
im land geteilt wird
sie müssen eine einheitsregierung bilden
und jeder soll mal sein ego
zurückstellen ich bin für eine
einheitsregierung aber ohne extremisten
auf beiden seiten für netanyahu geht es
nicht nur um sein amt ihm droht eine
anklage wegen korruption
sollte es soweit kommen wäre er als
regierungschef kaum noch tragbar sein
zenit so glauben beobachter ist auch
jetzt schon überschritten
er wollte mit seiner rechten koalition
61 sind um weiterzuregieren und einer
drohenden anklage durch ein
immunitätsgesetz
zu entgehen daraus wird nichts es ist
absehbar dass netanjahu das amt in
einigen wochen oder monaten abgeben muss
israel stehen jetzt schwierige
koalitionsverhandlungen bevor also
völlig offen ob netanyahu sich im amt
halten kann niko alm nicola albrecht in
tel aviv
aber jetzt ist sowieso erstmal der
staatspräsident am zug
absolut sobald alle stimmen ausgezählt
sind entscheidet staatspräsident rief
wen er mit der regierungsbildung
beauftragen will und dazu holt er sich
empfehlungen von allen fraktionen ein
die dürfen sagen wen sie als
premierminister unterstützen würden
und dann bekommt tatsächlich derjenige
den auftrag den präsidenten rivlin für
denjenigen hält der eine regierung
zustande bringen wird aber egal wer das
wiederum sein wird die
koalitionsverhandlungen werden schwierig
werden hart denn da steht die schlüssel
frage im raum wer darf den
premierminister stellen
netanyahu hat übrigens gerade noch
einmal bei einer pk seinem nicht
regierungsfähigen rechtsbündnis die
treue geschworen und somit indirekt
einer großen koalition die absage
erteilt doch auch das heißt zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt alles noch gar nicht das
einzige was feststeht ist dass es für
netanyahu eine schicksalswahl ist
dankeschön für diese informationen
nicola albrecht aus tel aviv
auch spanien tut sich schwer mit der
regierungsbildung der letzte versuch ist
gestern abend gescheitert jetzt gibt es
am 10 november neuwahlen zum vierten mal
innerhalb von vier jahren
der amtierende ministerpräsident sanchez
von den sozialisten auf den anderen
parteien vor eine einigung verhindert zu
haben
der chef der konservativen volkspartei
casado konterte sánchez habe nie
ernsthaft versucht eine koalition zu
bilden
diesen gehe es seit monaten um neuwahlen
wer steckt hinter den angriffen auf
ölanlagen in saudi arabien riad
verschärfte heute seine vorwürfe gegen
iran das verteidigungsministerium
präsentierte trümmerteile von drohnen
und matsch
körpern die beweisen sollen dass teheran
für die attacken vom samstag
verantwortlich ist die iranische führung
hat das mehrfach zurückgewiesen
us präsident kündigte an die sanktionen
gegen iran zu verstärken
im a team ist in washington angebliche
beweise neue sanktionen wo führte fing
ja hoffentlich nicht in einen krieg das
denken und jedenfalls auch hier in
washington sogar im weißen haus bei
donald trump im wahlkampf so überhaupt
keine eskalation in dieser region der
welt gebrauchen kann
er hat ja trotzdem sanktionen
angekündigt das muss er zunächst einmal
auch die trümmerteile die wir heute
gesehen haben aus saudi arabien
da ist man sich hier in washington
sicher zeigen tatsächlich die drohnen
und die raketen die beim angriff auf die
ölanlagen benutzt wurden
was aber weiter völlig offen ist von wo
wurden sie abgefeuert und wer hat sie
abgefeuert und wenn das dem mond klaren
bliebe wäre es der us regierung
wahrscheinlich recht weil sie es
vielleicht am ende bei sanktionen
belassen könnte aber es gibt ein problem
dabei wer dahintersteckt könnte das dann
wiederum als zeichen nehmen einfach
weiter zu eskalieren weitere angriffe zu
verüben so dass präsident trump immer
weiter unter druck gerät doch
militärisch zurückzuschlagen der
außenminister ist gerade in saudi
arabien angekommen um sich selber ein
bild zu machen und es wird wohl von
seinem bericht abhängen wie die
vereinigten staaten von amerika auf
diesen angriff reagieren
danke emma dieses nachrutschen nach
deutschland bundeswehrsoldaten sollen
sich weiter an der internationalen
mission gegen den sogenannten
islamischen staates beteiligen
das ist einer von mehreren wichtigen
kabinettsbeschlüssen tornado
überwachungsflüge über irak und syrien
und die ausbildung der irakischen armee
sollen bis 2020 fortgesetzt werden
um den anstieg der mieten zu bremsen
will die regierung für vergleichsmieten
künftig sechs jahre statt bisher vier
als grundlage nehmen und paketzusteller
sollen stärker vor ausbeutung geschützt
werden
die großen paketdienste sollen künftig
dafür haften wenn ihre subunternehmer
zum beispiel keinen mindestlohn zahlen
klaus bonsack berichtet
die branche boomt allein in diesem jahr
wird mit dreieinhalb milliarden paketen
in deutschland gerechnet
doch längst nicht jeder paketdienst
beschäftigt eigene zusteller und unter
den subunternehmern gibt es einige
schwarze schafe
es geht darum dass wir fairen wettbewerb
wollen das anständige unternehmen nicht
die dummen sein sollen dass wir aber vor
allen dingen faire arbeitsbedingungen
für die menschen in der branche brauchen
die da arbeiten recht und gesetz gelten
für alle und das wenn man dieser branche
jetzt durchsetzen
tatsächlich hat der zoll festgestellt
dass etliche sub unternehmer ihre
zusteller schlecht bezahlen oder gegen
das arbeitsrecht verstoßen
um die paketboten vor ausbeutung zu
schützen sollen die großen versand
dienste nun verpflichtet werden
sozialbeiträge für säumige
subunternehmer nachzuzahlen das allein
aber würde nicht reichen monieren die
linken
wir brauchen ausreichend kontrolle es
gibt genügend gesetzesverstöße die auch
schon vorher gesetzesverstöße waren die
nicht geahndet wurden solange der zoll
solange die anderen kontrollbehörden da
nicht ausreichend personal ausgestattet
werden wird es alles nichts bringen
das sind brauchen wir mehr personal die
regierung hofft das gesetz bis dezember
durch den bundestag zu bringen
gerade rechtzeitig also zur hochsaison
der paketdienste zum weihnachtsgeschäft
das bundeskabinett hat auch ein gesetz
zum abbau unnötiger bürokratie
beschlossen es soll vor allem firmen
aber auch arbeitnehmer entlasten eine
maßnahme ist der gelbe schein also die
krankmeldung soll digital werden bisher
geht so der angst gibt dem arbeitnehmer
eine krankmeldung in dreifacher
ausfertigung davon muss eine an die
krankenkasse geschickt werden eine an
den arbeitgeber und eine behält der
patient ab 2021 soll es einfacher werden
dann übermittelt der arzt die dann
papierlose krankmeldung digital an die
kasse von dort geht sie auch
elektronisch an den arbeitgeber das
system sollte gesetzlich versicherte
arbeitnehmer gelten
sie sparen dadurch laut bundesregierung
viel zeit und jährlich rund 77 millionen
portokosten
seit tagen rätseln experten warum in
nordrhein westfalen innerhalb kurzer
zeit mehrere babys mit viel gebildeten
händen auf die welt gekommen sind war
das zufall oder gibt es eine konkrete
ursache noch weiß das niemand
ärzte warnen vor voreiligen
schlussfolgerungen
jetzt werden forderungen laut nach einem
nationalen register um auffälligkeiten
leichter erkennen zu können
doch der vater berichtet vor 21 monaten
ist lily zur welt gekommen an ihrer
linken hand ist nur der daumen voll
ausgebildet eine fehlbildung ähnlich wie
bei den babys die jetzt in gelsenkirchen
zur welt gekommen sind
eine ursache dafür konnten die ärzte den
eltern nicht nennen
die fälle in gelsenkirchen rufen erneut
fragen in erinnerung
sofort denkt man sich als mutter ok hab
ich damals irgendwas falsch gemacht
hatte ich irgendwie war ich irgendwo
hatte ich irgendwas genommen oder so um
dann festzustellen die habe ich nicht
aber irgendwie habe ich im kopf sofort
wieder gedacht war irgendwas drei fälle
in kurzer zeit in dieser gelsenkirchener
klinik auffälligkeit oder bloßer zufall
die klinik wandte sich eine expertin der
berliner charité die untersuchen nun
zudem fragt das nordrhein westfälische
gesundheitsministerium jetzt alle
geburtskliniken im land nach daten bis
ende nächster woche sollen ergebnisse
vorliegen
ein nationales register gibt es nicht
nur einzelne erhebungen wie das
geburtenregister an der mainzer
universität die experten hier äußern
sich zurückhaltend wir haben ein signal
das bedeutet dass man mit einer höheren
sorgfalt jetzt diesbezüglich noch mal
abfragt bisher habe ich aber den
meldungen nicht ändern und dass man hier
über die bundesrepublik jetzt eine
erhöhte zahl von
solchen fehlbildungen oder
vergleichbaren fehlbildungen in kurzer
zeit gemeldet hat register seien wichtig
sagen die mainzer experten ein erster
schritt um nach ursachen zu forschen
die frage nach den ursachen spielt bei
lilly und ihrer familie im alltag längst
keine rolle mehr
lilly lernt und lacht so wie jedes kind
in ihrem alter bei mehreren
sendeanstalten der ard laufen heute
warnstreiks auch mit auswirkungen aufs
programm so konnten teile des
morgenmagazins nicht live ausgestrahlt
werden weil die mitarbeiter des wdr im
ausstand waren auch beim ndr legten
viele die arbeit nieder
im laufenden tarifstreit fordert die
gewerkschaft eine erhöhung der gehälter
und honorare die sich an den abschlüssen
im öffentlichen dienst orientiert das
angebot der sender liegt deutlich
darunter
die tafeln schlagen alarm immer mehr
bedürftige in deutschland sind auf
gespendete lebensmittel angewiesen vor
allem immer mehr senioren
bundesweit gibt es derzeit 947 tafel
ausgabestellen die meisten der rund
60.000 mitarbeiter arbeiten ehrenamtlich
jedes jahr tragen sie gut 265.000 tonnen
lebensmittel zusammen
und jetzt das was heute alarmiert die
zahl der tafelkunden stieg im letzten
jahr um zehn prozent auf 1,65 millionen
menschen romanesco berichtet mittags um
halb eins beginn der lebensmittelausgabe
die tafel der evangelischen
kirchengemeinde liegt im gutbürgerlichen
berliner bezirk charlottenburg auch hier
wächst die nachfrage gerade für rentner
ist es kein leichter gang
ich verstehe dass da eine schwere ist
und ich muss gestehen wenn ich noch mal
auf die welt komme werde ich vermeiden
in dieser situation zu kommen
ich bin regelmäßig jede woche hier weil
ich das geld was sich dadurch einsparen
im moment wirklich für mehr
gesundheitsausgaben brauche
deutschlandweit wächst der anteil der
rentner unter den tafeln nutzern am
stärksten 20 prozent mehr sind es im
vergleich zum vorjahr laut dachverband
sind insgesamt 430.000 senioren auf
lebensmittel der tafel angewiesen
wir glauben dass das eine
gesellschaftliche herausforderung auch
gesellschaftliche sprengkraft ist dass
menschen die in diesem land gearbeitet
haben offensichtlich nicht genug haben
um ihrem in ihrem alltag zurechtzukommen
rückgrat der tafeln bleiben die
ehrenamtlichen helfer deren geleistete
arbeitsstunden gehen aber zurück eine
aufwertung des ehrenamtes fordert daher
der dachverband
ich finde es extrem wichtig dass man
auch die bedingungen verbessert ob das
reisekosten sind fahrtkosten sind ob das
eben halt auch die anrechnung von
ehrenamt auf die rente ist wie wir sie
wie wir das geforderte man muss das
wieder attraktiver machen die denn fakt
ist die nachfrage bei den tafeln steigt
weiter und damit auch der bedarf an
ehrenamtlichen helfern kauft mehr
mehrwegflaschen fordern vor allem
umweltschützer immer wieder
der trend im supermarkt geht aber gerade
andersherum dort ist die nachfrage nach
mehrweg so gering wie er sank im jahr
2007 auf gerade noch 42 zum vergleich
2010 gab es noch 48 prozent
mehrwegflaschen aus plastik und glas
damit verfehlen handel und kunden die
freiwillige zielvorgabe im verpackungs
gesetz krachend dort sind eigentlich 70
prozent angepeilt
der norden deutschlands hat heute noch
mit den folgen des sturms von gestern zu
kämpfen erst nach und nach gibt die bahn
blockierte strecken wieder frei in der
nacht waren mehrere züge zwischen
hannover und hamburg steckengeblieben
umgestürzte bäume hatten oberleitungen
beschädigt und gleise blockiert
teilweise mussten passen
ihre stunden lang in den zügen ausharren
und damit sind wir beim sport bei
norbert runter champions league ja wohl
die top begegnung gestern abend dortmund
gegen barcelona starkes spiel starker
bvb aber am ende stand ist aus sicht der
dortmunder nur null zu null
wegen eines entscheidenden duells
bvb-stürmer reus machte keinen rein weil
barca torwart ter stegen alles sieht
keine antworten trotz einer
weltklasse-leistung marc andré ter
stegen barcelonas torwart gefeiert von
den spanischen medien als retter oder
deutsche mauer die nicht nur diesen
elfmeter von marco reus an sich
abprallen ließ
dann in ordnung oder gut und bisschen
mehr weil ein bisschen mehr glück kann
ich ihm vielleicht noch mal reinmachen
ohne hinweise ein privatduell zwischen
den beiden nationalspielern das ter
stegen für sich entschied
einzig an diesen ball von brandflow care
vorbei aber der war ja noch die latte 0
zu 0 am ende für die katalanen
schmeichelhaft rb leipzig dagegen nutzte
seine torchancen lissabon gewann gegen
benfica mit 221 erster champions league
sieg für trainer nagelsmann überhaupt
dank stürmer timo werner es ist eine
gala-vorstellung des torjägers in
lissabon doppelpack in der 69
nach den siebzigsten minute zur 2
0-führung leipzig kombiniert sich zum
auswärtserfolg
markant ist dass wir wirklich ja weniger
bälle nach vorne schlagen wir spielen
deutlich mehr hinten raus und lassen
hinten sie nicht zu für die portugiesen
reichte nur zum anschlusstor sechs
minuten vor dem ende
leipzig startet perfekt in die champions
league dem sieg gegen benfica soll in
leipzig gegen leon der nächste folgen
und heute abend spielen die bayern gegen
roter stern belgrad und leverkusen gegen
lokomotive moskau
titelverteidiger fc liverpool der hatte
gestern abend einen rabenschwarzen tag
und start erwischte in der gruppenphase
das team von jürgen klopp verlor beim
ssc neapel mit 0 2 die deutschen
volleyballer haben bei der
europameisterschaft im vierten spiel den
zweiten sieg errungen das dvv team
schlug die slowakei in antwerpen mit 13
0 sätzen deutschland hat damit schon das
achtelfinale erreicht eine niederlage
und einen sieg für die deutschen
tennisfrauen in fernost andrea petkovic
hat ihr achtelfinale in china verloren
angelique kerber in japan ist dagegen
weiter ihr erster sieg nach zweieinhalb
monaten im achtelfinale des wta-turniers
von osaka setzte sie sich gegen die us
amerikanerin nicole gibbs in zwei sätzen
mit 6 2 und 6 4 durch große
erleichterung bei angelique kerber das
mit dankeschön paris ist um eine
attraktion reicher sie zeigt sich mitten
auf der seen und sieht aus wie eine
mischung aus science fiction und james
bond ein wassertaxi namens zimbo das
zurzeit getestet wird elektrisch
angetrieben schwebt es auftrag flügen
über das wasser schon ab nächstem jahr
soll man eine fahrt buchen können und
die vollgestopften straßen sonst auch
entlasten fehlen noch die lottozahlen
die gewinnzahlen lauten 18 24 34 44 46
48 und die superzahl 8 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite 55 7
das wetter bleibt im süden sonnig im
norden bewölkt die details hat leicht
fester stimme im heute journal um
viertel vor zehn begrüßt sie marietta
slomka
wir danken für ihr interesse und
wünschen ihnen noch einen unbeschwerten
abend bis morgen wenn sie mögen auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
er geplant das satellitenbild von heute
zeigt uns dass zwischen dem tief und dem
hoch weiter kühle luft zu uns einfließt
und das erkennen wir an den kleinen
schäfchenwolken hier über der nordsee
die genau dann entstehen wenn nämlich
kühle luft über noch warmes wasser
streicht außerdem erkennen wir sehr gut
die wolken freie zone um dieses hoch die
sich jetzt zu uns ausdehnt aber besser
es auch wärmer wird dauert es noch ein
bisschen
besonders nachts kühlt es jetzt nämlich
erstmal außer an den küsten ordentlich
ab da haben wir doch tatsächlich
bodenfrostgefahr morgen früh in den
östlichen mittelgebirgen
meistens ist es nämlich auch klar nur
stellenweise gibt es nebel auch in der
feuchten luft von der nordsee
die ostsee schauer lassen nach und von
schauern gibt es auch morgen kaum welche
dafür umso mehr sonne vor allem im süden
und im südwesten vormittags auch noch im
nordosten und an der ostsee da kommen
dann nachmittags die dichteren wolken an
die insgesamt im norden unterwegs sind
wohl vor allem zwischen der nordsee und
dem erzgebirge
aber insgesamt ist das morgen ein
freundlicher tag mit klare luft wenn
auch etwas kühl bei nur 12 bis 18 grad
vielleicht am hochrhein auch mal 20 grad
aber am wochenende dann wird es deutlich
wärmer am sonntag bis 27 grad die sonne
setzt sich durch unter wind dreht auf
südost